what's up you guys so if you're a 90s
kid like me you've probably seen Devin
warkheiser he starred as Ned in the hit
Nickelodeon show Ned's Declassified
School Survival Guide he's worked
throughout a series of TV shows and
movies throughout the 2010s and today
he's revealing the Dark Side of child
acting that most people don't hear about
there's no air conditioning it was it
was a warehouse we're there to shoot a
show 12 hours a day under Hot Lights
he's also opening up about how much
money he made how much money he spent
and how he wound up completely broke so
these are The Good the Bad and the
horror stories of Nickelodeon stars as
soon as you subscribe and hit the like
button for the YouTube algorithm what
are you laughing Jack it's just funny it
works before you go into that if you
follow our Instagrams I'm sure you're
aware that Graham and I have been
traveling Non-Stop and when you're
traveling packing can be an absolute
nightmare I always have a tendency to to
over pack for clothes I like to have a
lot of options so when I go somewhere
and I'll have to film it's like you know
what do I want to wear but thankfully
our sponsor Unbound Marino reached out
to us to help Unbound Marino is a
clothing brand that uses the ultimate
travel fabric which is is Merino wool
which is perfectly optimized for packing
Comfort maximizing your travel
experience their Merino wool is
incredibly light moisture wicking and
odor resistant it's insanely comfortable
it just feels like I'm almost wearing
nothing whereas I'm wearing something
this feels like a completely foreign
material like I've never felt it before
it feels incredible and it is extremely
soft you know what the thing is it's a
very breathable material like you could
put it on it could be 90 degrees outside
but you still get like a bit of the wind
through it but it's warming at the sand
it's weird it's a weird sensation I like
it though and if you're a casual viewer
of the channel I'm sure you're also
aware that I struggle really badly with
having good style fortunately they sent
me this shirt and I know I'm gonna buy a
lot more of these shirts because I think
I actually look kind of good I'm not
gonna lie I wore this shirt four days in
a row without actually washing it and it
didn't smell at all I know that sounds
gross I know you don't want to hear that
but at the same point guys I literally
wore it four days in a row and the shirt
was perfectly fine and also here's the
thing guys if you're going to go out
shopping you may as well pick the
clothes that you're gonna wear for a
long time I can tell for something like
this this is something you're not going
to go to style it's very understated
there's no like crazy logos on it
anywhere that's going to be outdated in
a little bit something like this I think
it's classic it goes with pretty much
everything so if you're gonna buy a
staple item buy someone like this once
and then enjoy it because it's high
quality so if you guys are interested
use the link Down Below in the
description or you could go to Unbound
marino.com again the link is down below
in the description make sure to use the
code iced coffee for 10 off your order
enjoy let us know what you think and now
with that said let's get back to the
podcast the part that I struggle with is
that I was on my own show
at a young age and thought my career
after it would be nothing but uphill and
Jack oh I'm sorry
it's a FaceTime really you can't silence
a computer
it's okay
if you're watching this man come on it
was Sean yeah yeah Sean you [__] blew
it man okay all right let's get back to
it I'm so sorry oh no it's okay there's
a couple remnants of uh my childhood ego
that I struggle with and one of them is
that I booked my my own show I was the
lead on my own show and so I knew a
hundred percent like I am meant
to do and be great in this industry that
I love like I'm meant to be in movies
that that are great I'm meant to be in
more shows that are great
and
still haven't done anything as big as
Ned's and that is some weird thing to
reckon with that continues to Humble me
in good ways I think like I like who I
am I think my character is developed but
I still have this part of me that like
is like
no no I'm like I'm meant to be on all
the things I'm supposed to be in this
industry like and I caught it at such a
young age for me it was supposed to
continue forever and it hasn't
um
but I'm still gonna do it for the rest
of my life let's go back how did you get
started in acting uh I was just a little
ham I was just a little
it was just a kid who loved attention
and loved being funny and just like
loved movies and my parents saw it and
they were like hmm
I want to do community theater or
something do you want to do something
with this like I watch like Austin
Powers and uh Ace Ventura yeah and I
would just recite them at like six years
old I I used to have a photographic
memory kind of like I would see a movie
and just be able to recite most of it
and my parents were like yeah that's not
normal do you want to do a theater and I
was like yeah and then did theater for a
while and the theater people were like
do you want to audition for
commercials movies TV and I was like
yeah and did that and then that led to
LA and that led to Ned's and yeah what
do you mean that led to La so you didn't
grow up in a like correct no I grew up
in Georgia suburbs of suburbs of Atlanta
which is now a big uh entertainment Town
yeah it's it's like East Hollywood now
um but it wasn't then it was a right to
work state then which meant non-union
and so if the union isn't there no like
only non-union projects are filming
there which is like cheap and smaller
independent stuff so when I was there
there wasn't a lot of work there but
that's where I lived so that's where I
was auditioning and I booked a small
role in a movie called We Were Soldiers
it was a Mel Gibson film
um and how did you book that uh that was
just casting out of there you know it's
just did you know going in it was going
to be like a Mel Gibson yeah you did
yeah yeah I mean yeah that was just my
agents out there um I was a kid I was
just going and doing it like how really
uh 10 10 9 and that would have been
audition Mel Gibson was like at his PVP
at that time yeah we were soldiers was
it was it's a great film yeah um and he
was making it with Randall Wallace who
uh uh wrote Braveheart with him all
right yeah yeah it was like and huge
cast
um and they were casting his kids out of
Georgia because they were shooting in
Fort Benning Georgia so book that small
roll big movie and that led my Atlanta
agents to ask like do you want to go to
La for pilot season like we think you
should we have a connection with an
agent out there
um and yeah man what did that look like
was that Ned's Declassified uh or not
yet that no my first pilot season was
just auditions I did like an independent
movie and some things and then my second
pilot season was nuts and how did that
work were you just flying back and forth
between Georgia L.A yep yep yes it was
me and my mom uh my dad and sister would
stay in Georgia uh pilot season used to
be this thing in La that it's not
anymore pallet season used to be the
time of the year when most auditions
were happening when most Pilots were
being cast most new shows there was a
season of it it was January to like
April and that was the time for
auditions and then like a little bit in
September
um so people from all over the country
that would be the time you'd come and
you'd come for those four months and
that would be when you would hit all the
auditions and then go back to wherever
the hell you came from yeah nowadays
it's not that we're streaming
everything's all the time
um but yeah so we'd come out for four
months and then go back to Georgia and
then come back out book Ned's shot that
what were we doing for school by the way
like at that time so during Ned's I was
homeschooled six months of the year
while we shot Ned's and I was back in my
public Middle School uh in Georgia so
you were actual middle schooler while
you were shooting yeah and I was the
same age I was on the show so Ned was in
sixth grade I was in sixth grade and I
was in seventh grade I was in seventh
grade and it was an eighth
yeah how was that were you were the
people in your school being like only
for like a moment when I would first get
there and then you're just like in
school you know like kids
the the novelty like wears off very
quickly and then you're just another
student you know
um and people are judging you not based
on that but on like do I like this
person or not like you know do we have a
connection or not uh and I think that
like I had a really good version of the
child acting industry and I think that
was part of it was I'd come out here and
do la and then I'd go back and live like
the life that I grew up in with my
friends in my hometown in public school
for half the year and I think that was
like a nice balance of both it would
really ground me to go back home
um so that ego thing like was less yeah
that sounds smart and and also while you
were in middle school since you were
also playing the same obviously on in
the movie or in the show uh did you ever
have experiences in middle school you're
like hmm I could pitch this because this
is a funny like thing that occurred no
it's like it's on the writers man like
they have a whole team of writers who
have lived a lot of life and are very
funny people and and they had it
um for me it was more just getting
excited to see what they were writing
for us because Ned's was so funny and so
zany and we always got to do
crazy [__] I mean the show was a blast
it was basically a cartoon that we
filmed with real people but the size of
the jokes and the size of the world was
cartoon
um so yeah it was more just exciting
every table reading every season seeing
what we got to do I mean even going
through the re-watch Pod now I haven't
watched these episodes in so long and
now I'm watching through them and even
in the first season like the amount of
like gags were doing and like stunts and
I'm in like a giant beach ball and we
have like this mop bucket slingshot
thing and like everything's just so off
the wall
um it was always great getting episodes
like always great seeing what the new
jokes were gonna be so how did you land
Ned's uh it was a normal audition
process you know I had an agent they
sent the audition and then there's like
a rap there's series of auditions you go
to the first read with the casting
director then you go to the next read
with maybe a producer or two the Creator
uh from there they're starting to pick
favorites for each role and trying to do
a chemistry read they're trying to blend
different actors and read them in
different uh groupings to try and see
who who is the role you know so it was a
series of them so we had we had Ned's
the pilot got cast in waited a year to
find out if it was getting picked up uh
we found out
a year later hey congratulations it's
going to series
but one of the three cast members is
gonna get recast uh for a diversity hire
because we had three white kids and a
pilot
um and uh one of one of you are going to
be recast and so you have to come in and
Audition one last time wow after we made
the pilot yeah after booking the pilot
waiting to hear if it goes to series
like our our dreams are on the line for
this thing and it was like this
Bittersweet crazy phone call
congratulations it's going but also hold
on tight because you have to audition
again and we're gonna have to wait to
hear you prepare for that that was more
just like mental [__] was like I already
know what I'm doing in there like it's
gonna be the same scenes that I
auditioned with already five times and
filmed in the pilot like we're gonna do
the same scenes that booked me the role
it was about just just
owning what I already did and not
psyching myself out just owning like no
like I already booked this role do what
I did do what I do be comfortable and
just just do it so when you film for a
pilot do you know which network it's
going to be at that time yeah this is
you knew already it was gonna be yeah
not for every pilot sometimes people do
it kind of independent and then are
going to sell it but most of the time
the the studio is who's funding the
pilot sure they've been pitched the
pylon and they're like yeah we're gonna
make this and then we'll see we'll test
it and we'll see if we want to make it
so you knew is Nick were you a fan of
Nickelodeon of course yeah for your
favorite shows it was more of the
cartoons at the time but I guess no I
had watched so much Nickelodeon um
all that yeah
Arnold uh Pete and Pete oh my gosh
Nickelodeon yeah yeah I forgot about
that of course I'd watched all of that I
loved I loved Nickelodeon yeah yeah it
was fire to be on it that's so cool yeah
but first you want to think today's
spawn answers stream yard stream yard is
a live streaming software that allows
you to create high quality content with
the click of a button all you need is a
camera and an internet connection to be
able to stream directly from your
browser and one of my personal favorite
features is that they allow you to
multi-stream which basically means that
you can stream to Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn and more all at the same time I
also really enjoy that streamer offers
various analytic tools so that you can
measure the success of every single one
of your live streams and you're able to
see which platform is bringing in the
most traffic stream yard is really one
of the best ways to get started creating
content without spending any money
whatsoever and they also offer a free
package so that you can get started
without any risk whatsoever check out
streamier today with our link Down Below
in the description on top of all of
those incredible benefits they've also
just been an amazing supporter of the
podcast and they help us do what we do
every Sunday for you guys so it would
mean a lot if you check them out with
the link Down Below in the description
thank you so much stream yard and back
to the podcast it was also my second
pilot season in La so
it honestly man I hit
I don't know if you've ever read uh
what's that book The Alchemist
um it's like I think I did in high
school it's like an allegory for you
know following your your pursuit in life
but
but there's like a part where he talks
about beginner's luck kind of being life
showing you like Grace
early on to say yes pursue this thing
and then you'll meet your challenges but
like a little bit of beginner's luck is
like hey yeah here you go here's a
little Grace starting out casinos do the
same thing by the way exactly every
single time I'm like you know you're
gonna win that's what gets you hooked
man that's kind of what I'm saying is
like it's true my second pilot season I
booked Ned's and it just felt like oh
the path is just gonna like this this is
what I'm doing this is gonna be easy I
meant to do this it's all happening
um
that is not that is not always do you
remember what the pay was on like this
that first season I don't but whatever
it was it's less than what any of you
think it is that's that's what uh who
was it it was uh Josh said what 15K an
episode no I think that was it that
would have been that would have been
third season exactly that would have
been the end he was getting I think it
was 1500 or 3 000 an episode he said
that it was enough to move out on his
own to like a one bedroom apartment but
also now he's not getting I remember he
said he wasn't getting royalties anymore
which is really interesting he was on
Jason Nash's podcast and Jason is still
getting royalties from Drake and Josh
yeah but Josh wasn't because he was a
kid when he was doing it no because he
was Elite
oh wow no because he was Elite no
Nickelodeon worked out some crazy deal
with aftra at the time there's two
acting unions Sagan after a they're
merged now at sag-aftra uh they were
split at the time and I don't believe
sag ever would have let this happen but
it was an after show all Nickelodeon
shows were after and after
I don't know got
screwed and sold us out in uh
negotiations with Nickelodeon because
they were kind of Ruthless and um they
didn't pay their leads uh residuals
but like guest stars and recurring got
residuals because their initial pay was
so much less the residuals are going to
be less yeah no it does seem insane
doesn't it so it was a low amount for
the first season do you remember at all
what it was like in those those final
two seasons no but somewhere somewhere
up between 10 and 15K makes sense for
the final seasons and that was a big
show too yeah yeah yeah yeah you would
expect it to be so nowadays people are
getting paid like 100k an episode of
Modern Family or whatever
that's prime time that's Prime Time Abc
yeah no like no one's getting kid shows
were always less as a kid it was
something you know yeah it's not nothing
um but the the fact that it's like sold
all over the world repeatedly since and
there's no residuals on it is is just
some shrewd business from Nickelodeon
yeah you just don't really know what
you're signing as a kid you know
exactly what you're getting yeah we know
I mean it's not like I didn't have
lawyers and parents like no we knew
exactly what we were signing they just
will not change that they were like they
were like Alternatives saying no yeah I
mean no literally they call that bluff
they say We'll hire someone else in
between Seasons we were like okay the
show's doing well let's renegotiate
these residuals they're like we'll hire
we'll recast Ned right now would they re
do you think that looking back do you
think there's no way they could have
done that
[Music]
they're like look there are thousands of
kids across the country who would want
to do this yeah like they're Savages it
makes sense though because if you did
that that would set precedent where
everyone else would want to renegotiate
exactly and it would be very exactly and
also
it what am I gonna walk away from my
show like and the opportunity absolutely
not like they know of course I'm not
gonna but now it does seem like
Nickelodeon actors are a lot better off
afterwards than the Disney Channel actor
it's because we're like it's because
we're less famous do you think so yeah I
do honestly I do I think it's because
we're less famous
I mean not all of us like Nickelodeon
apparently there's a lot coming out with
a lot of Nickelodeon actors who have
[__] up experiences man it's right
yeah it breaks my heart to hear but no I
honestly think it's because we're less
famous Disney has a better machine
they have a better business I'd imagine
Nickelodeon be more like Hands-On and
like kind
I don't I don't know like from like my
random perspective this fan like Disney
is like they feel like that I think on a
corporate level they feel more that I
don't know uh they they were fine they
it was it was fine I had a good I had an
overall good experience on Nickelodeon
um but so did a bunch of the Disney kids
um
it really depends on who's running your
show
that's that's where it that's where it
happens is who's the creator of your
show who's the showrunner of your show
right how they are is gonna dictate the
vast majority of your experience while
making the show
um Ned's was made by a guy named Scott
fellows who is an incredible human he's
a great family man hilarious guy his
wife produces with him his kids are on
set like it was a blast Scott's
incredible and you know sets are a
hierarchy if your boss is not a good
leader and is kind of toxic and kind of
projected on people or whatever is
unaware of the responsibility they have
as a leader
um your job's gonna be very frustrating
like I've worked other jobs than acting
and man if a boss has uh some blind
spots or whatever
it's men it sucks sure it sucks
um
if your boss is a great leader and a
great person and actually cares about
the people who work for him and making
the environment
um function and connected and open and
and hard working then the experience is
going to be great and
um
yeah we had that on EDS we had a great
experience uh hearing from other kids
stars come out over the last few years
that some of their experiences were less
good so how involved were your parents
and like you know you working and making
sure like you're doing okay and super
involved yeah my mom especially because
she was the one out here with me my dad
was uh back in Georgia working right
um and he would come out a lot but my
mom my mom was on set with me every
single day and my mom is
she's the best she's the best and
she was always making sure
I'm good
what to watch out for
uh
stage mom stage mom is a term it's
parents who are aggressively pushy right
yeah yeah it's parents who want the kids
career more than the kid does and it
makes them not trustworthy people to be
around it makes them sketchy right like
stage moms are sketchy because their
motives are apparent and they're
aggressive and it's weird
um my mom was always watching out for
that and always making sure I knew what
to watch out for and
um she was on set like
keeping an eye and confronting what
would she be confronting one example was
she reminded me so first season we
filmed at one studio in Hollywood Sunset
Gower a proper soundstage based on the
great success of our show Nickelodeon
moved us to uh some shitty cheap Studio
out in the valley that's like a
converted Warehouse not a real Sound
Stage they were gonna try and make us
film there with no air conditioning
there was no air conditioning it was it
was a warehouse and oh those are hard to
to heat and cool I mean they basically
exposed to whatever the outside is is
the inside of a warehouse you're right
yeah but doesn't [__] matter like
we're there to shoot a show 12 hours a
day under hot lights in the valley
during parts of the summer like my mom's
like I don't care what it costs or what
you what are you gonna do you're not
going to air condition the set they're
like it's gonna cost a lot to bring in
you know AC and these these like big
like you can't even vent while you're
filming right don't they have to turn
them off oh for sure yeah yeah for sure
but you need them on when we're not
filming there's plenty of time we're not
filming
um
I didn't realize like my mom was kind of
who had to push that because she was
like what what did the other parents not
get involved to that degree or was your
mom the one who was like my mom was the
one man okay yeah she was she was the
one
I just thought it would be bad for the
show like you don't want to show up me
all sweaty yeah no it's exhausted what
you're trying to pray you know what
don't they have you wear multiple layers
of clothes like you would wear a shirt
yeah but still we'd be but we'd be but
not we'd be sweating man our faces our
hair uh yeah no it's it's a dumb idea to
not ultimately they had to air condition
it but I forgot about that whole thing I
forgot like we would stand in front of
these giant Yellow air conditioning
tubes and just like yeah yeah it was a
thing but but my mom was like I forgot
how much she was kind of like going to
bat to make sure everything was okay and
that's what it takes was this your
full-time job at that point for my mom
yeah wow yeah man I mean she was on set
every day I mean we're there 10 hours a
day so one thing I was curious about in
the show uh going back through some of
your podcasts you were in a relationship
with Lindsay how did that come to be and
were the producers worried that like two
of the actors were like maybe getting
involved and maybe like what if that
doesn't work out it's like no that's so
typical man it was it was the end of the
show we had worked together three years
yeah in the story Ned and Moe's are
coming together that season
and Devin and Lindsay off camera were
coming I mean it's just how did that
develop though after because I feel like
you just developed more of like a
friendship actually man naturally kids
with hormones spending a lot of time
together
I'm gonna say it it was it was it was
bound to happen you think it's hard for
guys and girls to be friends it can be
done of course it can I've got I've got
some of my best friends are girls but uh
keeping it emotionally clean keeping the
space clean keeping the communication
clean keeping the feelings clean is uh
you know it's not always easy someone
someone might develop feelings and if
that's uh incongruent if it's
not reciprocated in the way you want
navigating that can be difficult
um
but I don't know I've got great friends
that are girls so it seems like it's
easier every time they ask questions
like this on Tick Tock yeah guys girls
be friends all the girls are like yeah
we could be friends but every guy's like
nah nah the girls are like no of course
we could be friends and then they ask
the guy that's friends with that girl
and they're like if you know if you
could if you get over there in an
intimate way would you do it yourself
absolutely 100 yeah but if you ask girls
the same question almost all of them
would be like no we're just friends
right I think it's possible but it's
it's hard for both sides to be like on
the same wavelength that's it so that's
that's right that's why it's difficult
yeah that's why it's tricky and like I
said again I have best friends like
girls I will know for my entire life who
I love and cherish and we have amazing
friendships
um so of course it's possible it's
doable and you should you should not
only have guy friends if you're a guy
and as a girl you should have some dude
friends
but
it's challenging
Scott I've not deceive each other you
got to be really [__] real with
yourself and your friends and
intentional I guess yeah and intentional
and and clear about uh clear about
boundaries and clear about talking
through things and like you really have
to care for the each other's well-being
um because yeah just it can just get it
can just get messy
I don't know I don't know that I have
more to say on that I think it's fair in
my experience it's like you find a go
ahead I have a question for you guys
sure not just not just uh not just being
friends with girls because that's doable
of course there there are challenges but
it's doable
can you be friends with your exes
yeah no I think so I love it I love it I
just got two answers yes that's what I'm
talking about yeah why why no I think I
just move on and then mentally it's just
it didn't work out I have no interest in
becoming friends afterwards I'm sure
maybe there might be like something in
the in a very long future of just being
cordial I'd be cordial no matter what
actually uh I would never be like oh my
God I'd always be friendly sure but uh
but not friends no no desire respect
like no desire respect why yes well a
lot of the times you'll start out as
friends and then you can go to dating
and if dating doesn't work out like that
doesn't take away from the fact that you
were once friends so in those situations
I think I think it's a little easier it
depends on how intimate you got yeah I
would agree but I don't like
I just don't think that there's one
stereotype that you can say and sweep
for everything like I think of course
there will always be situations where
it's challenging and of course there
will be situations where it's fine yeah
it just depends on the people for me
personally I like to think I'm the type
of guy that could just be ah yeah sure
let's be friends whatever I guess
friends is also different than
acquaintances and wanting the best out
of the person and checking in every once
in a while but not like actual like
hangout friends yeah
um yeah I think if you want to be
friends you will right yeah I think
anything is possible if you just really
want it yeah I think too many people
want that and they aren't real about
why or the like yeah why why I'm more on
yours I agree with you that it's not one
size fits all I am I'm friends with
Lindsay she was my first love right but
I do feel don't you feel like it is
different as like a teen like it's your
kind of first relationship versus
something like yeah yeah absolutely like
Yeah x is in my 20s is different than
right 15. right but uh I think too many
people immediately go to well we'll just
be friends then yeah it's like that's
the worst it doesn't work like that
entirely I'm I'm more with you where
it's like you gotta go no contact we did
our thing yeah
we shared this transformational
experience good or bad
and we've been not just
physically naked with each other but
like spiritually naked with one another
we've we were intimate
and now it's over and goodbye what can
we ask what happens what what happened
with Lindsay yeah I mean we're 15. that
was never going to work out do you know
what I mean
there's still got to be something that
happened I feel like things happen but
like it doesn't matter it was never
going to work out I feel like you see
some stories though of people who met
and like very rare high school
did they really yeah yeah wow yeah they
had art class together but didn't they
did they stay together the whole time
but they weren't I think they had I had
one they had one break uh it might have
been when my dad went off to college or
something like that and they got back
together like a year later I think it
was spring break of 94. it was nuts yeah
I think that's it though yeah it's very
rare very rare
um so yeah like things happen but
ultimately we couldn't sustain a
relationship we were two different
people who had never loved people before
sure and what about dating for you now
what about it you got a girlfriend no
you on the apps no really yeah how do
you meet people
like you meet people without phone
though
you're not going public
yeah I meet people in the world and on
social media some of the time okay walk
us through and you know maybe at a
coffee shop
would blow up on Tinder like I guess I
was on for a minute during the pandemic
it didn't blow up that much
I I did the apps for the first time over
the pandemic because it was the first
time I was lonely enough and there was
no other option I was home alone so I
was like all right let me do these
things because the thing was when the
apps blew up I was in a long-term
relationship at the time so when they
became the thing that everyone was on I
wasn't dating and then I was recovering
from that I was heartbroken so I wasn't
[__] on apps pandemic hit I was
lonely enough and there was no other
chance to meet someone so I was like all
right let me download all these things
let me see what it's about
I see why people are doing it I get it I
met some nice people through it um but
ultimately
the the time spent like scrolling on
potential who this person could be me
judging based on their photos and like
their dumb little like that's not real I
don't even like I don't even like
getting to know someone over text like I
need to know like I can't
text is fun I keep text very like light
usually for a long time like I feel like
way too many people are
going through a very important part of
courtship and getting to know someone
over text
is that just we that's meant to weed out
the creepers that that's all it is like
can you continue a conversation like
somewhat normal yeah from their
perspective yes I get that but then you
have to get in person with that the
right time with the apps to get to a
date that I might know instantly like oh
this just ain't the vibe like great girl
not the vibe for me and I wouldn't know
it but now I do like I don't know I'm
just not it's not for me so I meet
people in person
how do you do that
you guys are amazing how do we meet her
so like how does she meet person so you
see somebody like you
yeah
you come here you can do that I don't
know like last weekend I was at a show
with some friends at an improv show with
some friends
um
there was a girl there who knew some of
my friends so just throughout the night
we had just had enough passing each
other little exchanges we happen to be
walking out of the bar at the same time
and then
um well she got my number but
but I could have gotten her number and
then I did get her number she asked for
your number she did she was proactive
she did which I loved did you did you
text her afterwards or you did yep cool
yep I love it I love proactive yeah I
love knowing like okay like that's a
good first step is like ah awesome you
a girl was brave enough to do the thing
and not just leave it on yeah
I like that yeah um but also I can do it
it's just about like do you feel a
little Vibe or whatever and you just go
talk and then if you feel something you
say hey can I get your number and it's a
little awkward and it's a little but uh
you just [__] do it man you think
you're a hopeless romantic not anymore
you used to be what changed experience
do you think it's better not to be or it
suits you more I think it's better not
to be entirely why I think romance is
amazing and intimacy is beautiful and
all of it has a place in our lives but
being a hopeless romantic idealizing and
fantasizing
ideas about what your relationship
should be and how it should fulfill you
I think is leading so many people wrong
yeah I think it's the expectation that
you put on another person I remember
there's there's someone in high school
and every guy she met was the one that
every single time and it would last
almost always six to eight months nasty
breakup and then right afterwards I met
the one that over and over and over
again yeah that that's being a hopeless
romantic over committing maybe over
committing
um not being real it's you're in
Fantasyland if you're you're being a
hopeless romantic you probably watch uh
romantic stories on movies and
television and you actually believe that
you want that they're not real they're
constructed stories between actors
they're not real Jim and Pam are not
real don't say that man they're not real
it's too far [__] it's fun to watch
it's entertaining but I think it's
actually poisoned to I would having a
real relationship I would tend to agree
with that there's so many relationships
on TVs that I see like that's that would
that would never exist and I think a lot
of it's unhealthy personally I know and
I think people are really because media
we relate to it I think people really
aren't aware how much they are adopting
the romance the Romantic ideas in movies
and television and actually putting it
and trying to put it on their real life
and it's just not it man I I did it I
did it I met someone who I thought was
the one I wanted to marry her I I was
the best
boyfriend I could be at the time I
played out the best version of like what
I thought this romance idea was and
there was a lot of it that was really
beautiful but where it got me
I learned too much from and I said hold
on all those things like that's not
what's important to me in love I'm not
even sure those things are love you
don't need to build this big Grand Story
you don't even need the story of the
[__] one like I don't need all that I
don't want all that it doesn't get you
it doesn't get me where I want to go
which is
which is a healthy relationship with
myself and another person which is
healthy boundaries which is being able
to
um discuss boundaries and respect one
another which is still being open
supportive romantic at times intimate
vulnerable these things are all still
included in what I want in Partnership
but these fantasies and these
conventions that everyone's a part of
I'm [__]
too old for this [__] man I'm over it I
played it out enough times I saw it
repeated enough times I've watched it in
other people people just bounce
oh yeah it's our it's our Dada
anniversary again oh I've watched you go
through like six of these with six
different the ones and every person is
completing you [__] that man
what like change how you approach this
thing
um that's how I I just don't approach it
the same I have a an aversion to Fantasy
in relationship now and not not some
kind of fantasy you know but these these
fantasies of like I'm gonna complete you
and I think people move way too [__]
fast at slotting someone into an idea
and into a feeling that they've seen on
[__] TV and it's just not
it man I completely agree Jack what do
you think
I agree people shouldn't get into
relationships for the sake of being
romantic or because they want romance
yes get into a relationship because you
like the other person yes you know you
think you're good together
yeah I would say I mostly agree but also
like I I maybe we have different
definitions of hopeless romantic like
people that are just so romantic and
that's what they think about and stuff
like that like that's fine it's just a
preference that's yeah you are you know
but of course don't let that make you
make irrational decisions yeah like I'll
give an example like like
like to me being a hopeless romantic is
not about the other per it's your it's
your filling in like an idea so I I was
overhearing I was overhearing a friend
of a friend talk and he was explaining
how he had kind of been talking to this
girl uh they hadn't met yet but they had
they had I don't know I guess been
linked up through friends and they've
been texting and talking over the phone
um a little bit and kind of you know
they were starting to be interested in
each other they were going to have their
first date so this guy probably
identifying as a hopeless romantic
um
sets up this elaborate first date this
[__]
picnic
and blindfold and blind first date and
tandem bicycle and just like way too
much and and it didn't go how he wanted
it to go and things are a little awkward
with the girl and I was overhearing this
just going like
well what the [__] are you doing man go
get coffee relax dude romance should
come like way for me like romance like
that should come way into a relationship
with someone when you know you show up
for each other when you know you've
respected each other when you've gotten
to really know someone like not just
doing a romantic thing on the first date
for someone like
see how'd it go it didn't go well it
didn't go well they're married with
three kids go well for him because of
course not it's too much
I feel like that happens did nobody tell
him before like yo don't do that did you
want him or like I didn't know him he
was a friend of friends so I was kind of
just hearing this and I didn't know him
well enough to go like he needs better
friends I agree yeah I agree because I
wanted to be like hey dude I don't know
you but like that what are you doing you
did too much he's already lost at that
point I agree yeah he's already I agree
yeah but this is out of some like
romantic ideal rather than like just go
meet someone take it slow everyone can
take it slow slow down you think a movie
would do well that accurately reflected
what you about no real romance
you don't think people would relate to
it or like I actually don't know if you
go against the grain if everybody's so
used to this like archetype or this
General movie plot if you go against the
grain try something different I know
some people do it there's been like
Friends with Benefits movies and there's
been heartbreaking movies like Blue
Valentine that show the a real
relationship falling apart it has been
done but it's still not what a real full
full dimensional life is
movies is a medium they are characters
on a plot line like it represents life
it's not life it can't it's
any artistic medium
um has to cut things out to make it work
like it's not everything the Highlight
Reel not just the Highlight Reel it's
characters on a story yeah our life is a
million things at one time getting to
know someone is a million things at one
time negotiating how we share with one
another or boundaries or what we need
our needs and wants it just doesn't go
the movie a character needs to go on a
[__] plot arc our life is going on a
million of these things at one time like
it's just not
it's not it so you can watch them and
maybe try and take Parts but I just
think I just no no that is not romance
it's not romance man it's crafted by a
Hollywood screenwriter it's beautiful
it's great storytelling but your life is
so much more than that getting to know
someone is so much more than two
characters having a scripted
conversation so do you feel like you're
at a point now where you're ready for a
relationship or do you feel like you
still have more like just
self-reflection growing to do and like
yeah no um I don't want I don't want one
okay uh uh smart man I don't want one I
do feel ready for one I know
I know my Pace these days is way
different and I will spend I will keep
things
I will keep things at a healthy distance
while still getting to know someone for
a lot longer and if someone is right
enough during that process and it keeps
unfolding in this way beautiful I could
see that happening sure I found most uh
of my relationships these days
um
haven't
uh they're not sustainable but I think
that's more realistic I don't think any
relationship is sustainable so if we can
start
if we can start not on the fantasy that
we're going to be together forever but
that like my life's super Dynamic it
changes all the time let's just keep
getting to know each other and keep
being good to one another and see where
this goes that's kind of where I've been
at these days and I've gotten to know
some great people
um some things have fizzled out
naturally and even that's been lovely
man so I do think I'm capable of being
in a relationship I don't think I want
one yeah it seems like La though people
do settle down way later yeah so yeah I
mean it's almost like the norm I feel
like to really start settling down at
least here in like your 40s it seems
like that's about well also like I'm a
[__] actor man like my life changes
all the time it can change in a phone
call like and then I go and shoot in
another city for a couple months or
whatever like
I've I've grown loving and accepting of
the the way my life is dynamic if I
lived in a one town uh and kind of my
life kind of structure I'd probably want
a girlfriend I'd want that I'd want to
build that I'd want to do that I'm so
aware that my life is changing all the
time and that I want it to yeah
that's not
that's not the best grounds for like a
relationship like hey I love this right
now but also I'm always counting on the
fact that my life is going to change or
that it's going to take me to new places
like next year
that's not the most stable like okay you
can count on me being here it seems very
exciting though that's real life where
it's like it could change every phone
call every text you get every day is
like a new opportunity there is
something exciting about that yeah it's
maddening but it's exciting and I'm
[__] I'm back on I'm back on it in a
very real way that makes me like I'm
stoked about it yeah I know I'm stoked
what about your music yeah music's
pretty good thanks man yeah thanks uh
music's been a journey I've been doing
that since I was 15. uh it is uh I was
doing a lot during the pandemic and then
2021 something creatively died in me
musically for the last couple years and
uh it's slowly starting to come back
around so I don't have any news to
report except that I will make new music
at some point and uh what kind of what
crushed it for you there I don't know
man just the creativity
yeah like literally something in my
creative connection to it
something it's a natural process I've
grown used to knowing myself well enough
that like it like really just like
skidded to a halt and died and I felt it
I was like whoa I'm like not connected
to any of my music and usually when that
happens I don't fight it sure I don't I
don't resist
like creativity is so natural to me if
it's not happening especially with music
I'm so connected to it I knew like oh I
can't fight this I just actually need to
let all of this whatever this process
there's a lot in our life we think we
can control there's there's a lot that's
just happening man and if you can just
pay attention to it if you can get to
know your into tuition well enough you
just gotta like let some of these
processes happen sometimes sometimes
we're going through changes that we
didn't choose but it's just our life man
cycles of our life are like playing
themselves out and creativity
is a natural cycle and death is a part
of creativity it's like people who could
just create music like that though it
could like just flip a switch like that
sort of create a mind I just I love that
oh me too yeah I love it and it's
starting to flow again I'm starting to
experiment and yes I I lose I know I
love it because I lose time doing it
like I'll sit down and all of a sudden
it's midnight and I've been like sitting
at my desk for eight hours like making
music and it feels so good what's your
creative process like
um these days it's different so one of
the things that that kind of died for me
musical musically was I had written
every song I'd ever written on guitar
pretty much and I just got
tired of that and so now I'm forging
into
experimenting with bedroom producing you
know starting with just not guitar
starting with a beat starting with
something on keys and just like crafting
songs differently
um and it's really just I don't know
it's just a beautiful flowing process I
don't know maybe I think a little weed
and I just [__] try and find try and
find a vibe that feels it's just like
this deep beautiful listening to myself
and life and what's coming through me
and I love it man I'm excited there's
there's some new music coming this year
I can already feel it starting to cook
it's in the it's in the unmanifest it's
in the potential side of life right now
and I can feel it just like whispering
to me it's gonna be great you know who's
back Skrillex have you seen yes his new
records are fine you drop two new
records and they're sick so you know
what's so crazy is like a few months ago
I was thinking whatever happened to
Skrillex like and I don't care yeah but
here I am thinking like I haven't seen
or heard of him in like 10 years and
then all of a sudden he comes up on my
Tick Tock in the back of an Uber yeah
he's like on his computer yeah and he's
like look at what I just came up with
and I don't know if this is real I tend
to believe that like he's just crafting
stuff and yeah Uber really good stuff
yeah I mean they could have made that
leave it they could have made that for
the gram but yeah still no he's a he's a
incredible musician he he is glad he's
back oh he's amazing yeah
oh you didn't know that no it's a very
diverse uh he does hell yeah eclectic
music but Skrillex do yeah Skrillex
never left not really I feel like I feel
like he did but his music because he's
been out there working like you right
yeah musicians are always doing scenes
and he was so big like he's been out
there doing D I mean he's been at
Burning Man every year doing sick DJ
sets like I guess I'm thinking more like
the mainstream yeah yeah he's been on
the radio stream but yeah he's been out
there crashing DJ set the cool thing
about being a DJ man is you can just go
get jobs all over the world whenever you
want if you're that big yes you can just
book a show in any City and get a bunch
of money and then go travel and do what
you do like you know because even if
you're not in the mainstream radio play
Skrillex showing up to any club in any
city in the world
gonna be fire yeah um and I'm sure he's
been doing it that whole time I got to
work with uh Steve Aoki on a movie oh
that's cool yes he's so funny he's great
yeah Steve's So Dope uh we've done some
Pokemon unboxings with him yeah man yeah
uh he's insane he's like one of the most
touring DJs in the world he like tours
like 300 days out of the year yeah he's
got his residency too in uh Vegas yep
and he takes people and it's a blast
I've been caked by him you've been caked
yeah it was an honor how does it planned
out or did kinda I mean it was at a show
but he knew it was while he was in a
movie I was shooting so he knew like me
and some of the cast were gonna be there
and caked us that's awesome how did that
happen what do you mean did he just like
were you in a crowd or was he just like
yeah in the crowd did he look at you
yeah it's just like yeah dude have you
seen him do this yeah on I feel so bad
for the person though no they love it
they won it but ruined mine this man's
aim this man is insane he does this at
every show he points at someone like
farther away and throws a cat like a
huge case
it's a full birthday cake man's amazing
he hits them in the face every time his
aim's impeccable I always think I'm a
big fan like you see these people
they're wearing nice clothes out but a
lot of makeup on you know yeah but the
amount of people that can say they've
been caked by Steve Aoki I mean it's
either face like just oh no it's a
sticky mess oh it's a mess man it's a
mentally and just like what do you oh
it's a mess you have to leave you have
to go shower we were covered in sugar it
was crazy but it's so fun
but it ends the night nah the night's
done no there's no shower
decision that's a mentality exactly
yeah dude people are gonna [__] eat
you it's awesome
you want people licking your head
sounds terrible yeah I gotta live a
little man but he goes on also so late
like he goes on at like two to three
o'clock in the morning I'm fast asleep
at that time yeah yeah you gotta you
gotta rage a little bit sometimes Graham
oh Graham just Graham you guys same age
completely different oh I know but I
don't think you would race he has money
and I don't so maybe there's something
there I don't I don't think you would
rage like what time would you go to bed
look like regularly yeah like normal
schedule I'm going to bed at like
midnight right before but no I can reach
her
yeah
yeah it's all about balance yeah I was I
was up to like five on Saturday like
Jack and I had a good night yeah I had a
good night 5am where did you go uh we
went to a club on the west side or a bar
on the West Side there's a little
birthday celebration I'm not sharing my
spots okay I'm not sharing my spots on
the podcast well we we like to go to
Main Street main Street's fun we go out
and about I like the Bungalow Bungalows
yeah bungalow's all right all right it's
all right see I'm not an LA guy so if I
do know
I'm not cheating on Bangla I don't go
there but it's a Vibe is a Vibe good or
bad I can't a vibe's good vibe is good
yeah the vibe's A vibe it means it's
something like it's it's it's got a Vibe
it's got It's not like yeah Dave and
Busters
yeah the thing is it's either it is a
Vibe or you bring the vibe okay you
usually don't want to have to bring the
vibe that's it but if it's not already
there sometimes exactly so it's nice
when it's the work is already done for
you the environment it already has this
facility Vibe it's not good yeah a whole
bunch of strangers though sometimes I
like the the atmosphere yeah Bungalow
early when there's not a lot of people I
like that and Logan gets so crowded yeah
we went to a spot in Nashville
terrible night terrible it was like sick
High food poisoning make sure that was
just that was just ramping up so like I
was okay to be out but it was just like
starting to feel a little queasy yeah
but it was these buildings there were
like six stories for
no there were more than four there were
more than four stories but you see each
level is its own club yeah and they have
all the windows all the windows open you
just walk up the steps there's like a
club walk up the steps Club yeah six
stories yeah stacked terrible yeah it
was terrible Different Strokes for
different folks man yeah loud music you
gotta push people to get around live
music's fun the floor was doing this
yeah that was scoring Graham yeah
because it was so loud you can't hear
anything so you can't talk no that's a
difficult part yeah no but you you don't
strike me as a dancer Graham I hate
dancing uh yeah see there's your problem
there's your problem right there it's
just not going to be for you like when I
go out I go dance you dance I just dance
man how do you do that what do you mean
what do you mean Instagram it's not
about thinking you're in your eyes I
love that question you just asked how do
you dance you mean you're dancing yeah
more than half the people watching this
have no idea music and you move your
body you turn off your brain your brain
is completely off and you're just kind
of having a good time exactly your arms
tapping your feet obviously the only
thing that really matters is a rhythm so
yeah find the rhythm of the song you
just worry people are watching me
they're not because no one's watching it
the thing is you're in your head that's
it you have to turn off your brain and
just exist and feel always like
someone's gonna be like oh look at that
guy dance he's trying to dance that guy
is so much more insecure than you I got
a question that I feel like I know the
answer to but you ever done psychedelic
script no I knew you haven't
why I'm just gonna leave that there no
no I'm curious no tell me tell me I'm
curious
yeah well because to dance you have to
get out of your head and getting out of
your head can be very hard for a lot of
people
um and uh psychedelics won't always do
it but that's one way to literally have
an experience where you go oh I let go
of my mind for a moment and everything
I'd be afraid of being changed after
that like because I I've seen some
people have tried it and then afterwards
they're not the same person and I like
who I am as a person so like I don't
want to risk that that's fair and then I
think what's the benefit oh maybe I
could dance at some point in the future
like is that is that worth the trip no
it sounds like incredible I don't like
dance I don't like it yeah and you might
not ever like it but dancing is
incredible it's not that you don't like
dancing you just don't like being
uncomfortable and because dancing isn't
something that comes naturally to you
nor is it something that like you I
don't practice it's different and and
don't enjoy trying something new for you
is uncomfortable no it's not that you
don't enjoy if you knew how to dance you
would enjoy it I think so that's it if
you felt it's free enough to even
discover how to dance
[Music]
it's also like inherent to our social
structures and biology through Malay
look at this from technological
perspective I know but look at that and
I'm like look at them moving their body
in such a way to a beat it's just
strange to comprehend that it's like but
logically this is something inherent to
our Humanity that's been around for
Millennia but if I look at like
like in nature you don't see any other
like you do like I don't know like you
don't see frogs just going like I do
bump into your lips
no you do you see yeah you see birds
birds you see birds okay maybe birds
mating dances or anything it's just
weird I don't know it's not weird man
and also if it is weird what's so bad
about being weird that's what I gotta
know
but that's why I was curious yeah night
out's not gonna be your thing because it
is too loud to talk that's one of the
things I don't love about going out or
it's one of the things I don't love
about trying to meet a woman out is I
can't actually hear if it's a stranger
stranger yeah like we can dance for a
moment and maybe we have an attraction
but if I can't like actually talk
without yelling like it's too hard to
have that first conversation so I don't
love that
um but I do love just going to dance me
my friends we just go down my guy
friends like we go yeah you go to just
let loose forget about everything that's
happening in your life get out of your
head you just go you listen to music and
you just have fun you just that's it
that's it I love watching your face
process this sounds exhausting it's just
not like that wouldn't relax me it's
okay it's getting into a flow state
where you're not just like constantly
thinking that's all it is and you have
your own ways of getting into your Flow
State that will work for you but the
thing is doesn't matter like you can try
out other other ways like when you when
you make music because I know you like
making music when you play piano when
you edit like those are times where you
get into a flow State that's true yeah
even when you're at the gym then dance
but
but you dislike it before you give it an
honest I've given it effort no you're
having it Macy's drag me on this no you
haven't set yourself free but I've been
set yourself free if you ever if you
ever accidentally end up at Burning Man
and accidentally take some ecstasy and
listen to Skrillex you're gonna dance no
I don't think that's ever gonna happen I
like I said accidentally you stumble
upon burning and then you stumble into
some ecstasy you don't of course not I'm
just saying to get through this barrier
around dance he might need the drugs a
hard case Jack yeah he might need the
drugs
[Music]
that's not entirely true I I will say in
in my psychedelic experience
um no you can have an experience on
psychedelics why I'm very excited that
the FDA is getting closer to approving
psychedelic assisted therapy yeah um you
can have an experience uh on a
psychedelic that
changes your life moving forward sober
it can show you a spectrum of what's
possible inside yourself in terms of
like acceptance love expression
integrating yourself and do it in a way
that even when you come off it you go oh
wow I know something different about
myself in the world now even if you do
them once or twice it's why I'm very I'm
really stoked for the work that's being
done to bring them into the like therapy
space bring them into the PTSD space
bring them into maybe couples therapy
space
[Music]
um
and do it with a protocol like through
the FDA that's like really safe and
really regulated I think that's a great
thing for our society to be honest yeah
because like I did it I had great
experiences but I did it the normal
Reckless way of just like being
somewhere and taking [__] right and
ending up having some great experiences
that have really enriched my life but
that is uh there's a lot of variables to
those experiences and doing it through
like an actual like regulated body I
think is nice it's gonna be good for the
world yeah yeah so one day well when
you're in there I'll say doing
doing assist psychedelic assistive
therapy and uh the MDMA is coursing
through your veins and they put on
Skrillex oh God a little Graham
in his little private space yeah
and your head's gonna bomb tap like
you've never tapped before gonna feel
free and not uncomfortable and I hope in
that moment Graham
you think of Devon workheiser okay I
hope you think of this conversation and
you say Ned told me
that is everywhere in nowhere at the
same time
Ned's dancing guide this would be funny
as a Ned's Survival guy like tip number
like two three two seconds two
psychedelic assisted therapy and free up
your ability to dance oh that's a good
way to end honestly that's a great final
tip we can't protect that well thank you
so much what do you want to shout it
who's your audience
18 to 35 85 male man it's similar to
mine so what's up guys
um
if you like podcasts I have growing up
with Devin new episodes are every
Tuesday that's that's my Exploration
with people
um about the transition between
adolescence and adulthood and it covers
a lot of different topics and I
interview a lot of different people a
lot of uh former entertainers you know
or still entertainers Ned's cast I've
got Lindsay and Daniel on there
um Kendall from Big Time Rush my friend
Jax who's an amazing singer-songwriter
Allison Stoner like there's tons of
great people I had great Finance people
on uh Tori Dunlap who I love uh her
first 100K she gave us a great talk on
finances
um but that's just my it's that
exploration the transition from
adolescence to adulthood is is uh
different for all of us but there's so
much that is the same and so I interview
guests on that and it's entertaining and
also I hope uh meaningful and
inspirational and then the Ned's pod
re-watch pod it's utter Insanity we talk
about pooping half the time it's it's a
it's a great time uh with me Lindsay and
Daniel new episodes every Wednesday
what else that's kind of it for now
there's there's a lot in the works but
that's the deal right now go check out
my pods and say hi to me on social media
you know you kind of look similar to Bo
Burnham I've heard that before I think
it's the beard it's the beard I was
noticing that halfway through the
podcast like who does he look like Bo
Burnham I love Bo Burnham he's good I
did a tick tock uh after watching inside
uh where I I play on that idea that I
look like Bo Burnham all right follow
him on Tick Tock guys follow me on Tick
Tock thank you so much thanks for having
me I think we could help with this let
us know I will I need a house no all
right I'm just kidding I love renting
all right
good luck editing man
foreign